this is in fact how we have gotten to
this place in our culture because
um because people are too afraid to just
say what they actually think about this
and because we've been so afraid that a
lot of it is our is our you know our
politeness our
empathy being used against us used
against us in such a way that this this
lie this Insanity has uh taken over our
culture you know this this emotional
manipulation of well you can't say that
because it might we'll hurt their
feelings they might hurt themselves you
know it's it's uh that's what it is it's
an emotional blackmail and we can't hope
to get to a point where truth prevails
in our culture until we're willing to
say I'm not gonna I'm not gonna be
blackmailed okay for the same reason we
won't negotiate with terrorists this is
like an emotional terrorism that they're
uh engaging in